is the one the only well what do you
know that's me I am the game with $2,500
for one of our couples and if any of
them say the secret why'd the secret
word boys will fly down and pay him $100
the way tonight is door George Fenneman
whose fights to try for the $2,500 CEO
loans just before we went on the air we
asked a very young single people present
tonight and our studio audience selected
miss Nina Kramer mr. Clarence alum and
he'll er folks come on in here and meet
groucho marx well welcome welcome for
the DeSoto Plymouth dealers and you say
the secret word you'll divide a hundred
dollars it's a common word something
you'll find around the house you're both
singly and would like to get married
someday
mr. Nina means that the way I announce
at 900
I see no Atena name nine
oh where are you where you from Niner
I'm originally from Chicago uh-huh
how original were you in Chicago 19
years ago 19 is oh then you've been here
about two years is that right no I've
been here about 10 years
oh you're not 29 I am now you got me
confused no I'm 19 he left you not or 19
years ago and you're 19 years old no I
was 19 how did you come out by bassinet
well you would you mind repeating that
whole thing again
how old are you I'm 19 19 yeah
how long since you left Chicago oh about
ten years
oh I see that would make you 14 years
old you could leave it at that okay and
what's your hometown Sonny Boy
Clarence I'm from Claremont California
claremont claremont that was an Oklahoma
it's not the one in California
probably not and I guess the one in
Oklahoma is not the same one that's in
California
that's why Will Rogers come so mean so
he does glamour say now you blind
something tonight
I'll cost you $3 what is your age
Clarence I'm 25
what kind of work do you do clearance
I'm a geologist don't change the subject
I ask you what kind of work well or a
geologists are really doing a wonderful
work these days now what do they do all
we study rocks hunt for minerals hunt
for oil hunt for anything valuable in
the Earth's surface you actually left
four rocks is that it that's right just
want to be sure in this program we never
take anything for granted you know
stop groaning it's free you know this
nobody forced you to come down here
I could have used all your tickets now
as a mining engineer what would you say
is the most valuable mineral I'd say
coal you would huh
go bring a girl a wedding ring made out
of coal how about uranium do you ever
look for that oh yes we look for uranium
although it's scarce enough around here
so normally it's only when we're looking
for some other mineral as well you mean
if you want to find uranium you have to
look for something else well that's what
we do yes it's kind of ridiculous why
don't you start out looking for uranium
now maybe you'll find coal hi Clarence
oh you're a nice guy I like you and I
want to see you and I know well provided
for your married life tell you what you
do you give me a dollar and I'll tell
you where you can find uranium okay no I
know where I can find uranium myself oh
you do I do - in the dictionary that's
an old gag
what sort of work do you do I'm a
librarian a librarian really is that so
I didn't realize librarians came this
young hello there lots of young girls
aren't you unusual yeah what's that
there are lots of young girls in
libraries oh is that so
[Music]
I guess I'll have to start reading again
I used to belong to the crook of the
month is that there now what what
library do you work for
the Beverly Hills public library really
I live in Beverly Hills I don't think
I've been barren where's it located well
it's in the City Hall right next to the
police station I've been there alright
on the other hand maybe why's the
library as I recall they booked me at
the time
Alessia where you work together as a
team around just one minute you're gonna
play you bet your life for a chance of
$2,500 but first there's something I
want you to pay close attention to it'll
prove invaluable in your marriage the
dollars you selected animals and nicer e
rhymes here's your first question how
much will you bet Oh 18 sounds 18 all
right what kind of a pet at all Mother
Hubbard her a dog a dog is correct
you're on your way you have 38 dollars
remember you're going for $2,500 9 now
how much is a 38 you gonna bet on this
one 36 36 what ran after the farmer's
wife
three three blind mice
[Applause]
have $74 $74 here's your fake question
how much you gonna go for 77373 why did
bo-peep 10 sheep sheep is right
[Applause]
[Music]
can I half the bride's I guess is
nothing you have 147 dollars here's your
last chance to be the other couples how
much you gonna bet 147 how's the saying
how mature they got already second is
any moment okay hold on gay why did Tom
the Piper's son swipe pig a pig is right
[Applause]
so why not the grandpa
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry
[Applause]
the officer for the program tonight and
just before we went on the air our
studio audience selected major Crossley
his partner is a housewife from the
audience
mrs. Sylvia Sparks folks come on here
and meet groucho marx well welcome to
your venture life fair say the secret
word and you'll divide 100 dollars it's
a common way something you'll find
around the house mrs. Sylvia sparks yeah
you're the housewife huh yeah you look
like you could give off many sparks I
used to wonder who was Sylvia
[Music]
where you from sell new George you from
New York yeah uh-huh
what does your husband do he's a
mechanical engineer at Norris Tampa
manufacturing company and major Ross
Crosley yeah what is your hometown major
my home is Columbus Ohio
are you married major yes sir very much
so
did you volunteer or were you drafted
sir uh I've volunteered should have
married the army after 20 years the army
gives you a pension how long you been
married Sylvia for a man four months in
place timeout
[Music]
let me save the race dragons good enough
for me married four months sir how long
you been married major uh brownish you
up some decorations on was that from the
marriage no I've been Mary service at
home in the kitchen
no uh Groucho I've been married for 13
years now which branch of the service
here you live uh I'm in the
quartermaster Corps now what do you do
as a quarter master
well we supervise the procurement of
perishable foods for the Armed Forces
well like what for example well like
like meats and dairy products and fresh
fruits and vegetables eggs butter would
you a retail or wholesale price well we
we pay wholesale prices we can't afford
to to pay retail prices because we buy
in such large volumes I buy in small
quantities and I can't afford to pay
retail price and when you buy in such
large quantities how do you know you're
not getting stung we have everything
inspected groucho if we for example if
we buy me why we have the veterinarian
inspect all of it when you buy you meet
Santa Anita
[Music]
we buy our meat in the matter as I just
told you from the packing houses and so
forth I suppose you buy a carload of
strawberries do you turn the train over
to see you the bad ones around the
bottom
no we how do you know that all right be
good we have we have inspectors look at
the strawberries what are they are they
on the bottom of the car well they don't
turn the whole bottom over but they may
pick a crate here and crate there and
then sometimes I'd look on the bottom
too well by the way is a quartermaster
would you say the army travels on its
stomach yes yeah definitely yes you ask
me quite aside after a 20-mile hike all
those soldiers soaking their tired
stomachs in a bucket of long water
[Music]
right now suppose you're buying me for
your own home what do you look for you
you mrs. bonks the butcher
oh that is there's one butcher I usually
go to you look at the bunch of fights
yeah I asked him mrs. sparks Uncle Sam
needs you if there were more women like
you and the service the army would stop
traveling on the stomach they'd get up
on their toes and follow you
well I've learned a lot about shopping
tonight now let's see if you took and
win a little grocery money you might win
$2,500 run your $20.00 in the more than
our other couples I can't tell you how
much our place couple one but Fenneman
zob states room I know isn't the
librarian and the engineer one $294 here
we go let's your hiking buddy twenty
dollars you selected George Washington
as your subject is your price question
how much would you bet hmm let's make it
15 15 15 what is the name of George
Washington's home Mont Vernon Mount
Vernon is correct yeah $35 you'd have
missed that major it have been drummed
out of the army do um you're going for
$2,500 a night no how much is it 35 you
gonna go for Oh we'll go for 20 20 is
that all right mrs. Fox
what's the fight's name of George
Washington Martha is right
you know it $55 he's saying he had a lot
of candy stars at one time yeah here's
you that question how much of the 55 you
gonna bet some we're better at all
you're gonna bet the 55 all right where
did washings Army spend the bitter
winter of 1777 Valley for dark
[Applause]
got 110 dollars and these your last
chance to beat the others now how much
you gonna bet my t90 is that all right
Tim Sylvia in what state was George
Washington born Virginia Virginia is
correct
[Music]
[Applause]
and you wind up with the rash go through
this thing on YouTube fell on aha
you ran up with a grand total of $200
and thank you very much
I gotcha yeah the secret word is still
dope talk slowly I hit a dragon all
right I was going to say that we invited
some girls swimmers to the program
tonight and just before we went in the
air our studio audience selected normal
welts her partner is a sculptor
mr. Yuka Sala Munich and Gilly are
welcome folks but the DeSoto Plymouth
dealers say just a good word and divide
a hundred dollars it's a common way
something you'll find around the house a
girl swimmer in a sculptor a normal
Wells's is it that's right yucca Sala
Munich that's right that's a very famous
name I've often seen it in the menu at
the brown Davey
[Music]
you're some kind of an odd day about you
no I'm hunter Oh a sculptor it's quite a
jump from orders how did you ever get a
name like your Cassell immunity just
like you did my parents give it to me as
far as I know your parents didn't even
know me now what is your name mean and
the brown David I mean that means salt
of Munich it means we're sort of Munich
salted my own accounts right oh where
are you from mr. Selim you know I was
born in Yugoslavia
why did you come to California my doctor
advised me to get rid of my sinus
trouble ahead and did you get rid of
your sinus he'd give
[Music]
you say you didn't get rid of your
signers no it's worse than before
[Music]
that case is a good thing you came to
California at least you did get ready a
doctor
[Music]
thank you could you sound off in
Yugoslavian Yaka sure I speak it very
well you know go ahead say something de
mas real mad dough blue blue
oh you're a southern
[Music]
okay I give up what did you say you have
very interesting head
[Music]
reading nothing here matter of fact it
is nothing I've seen better heads on a
glass of beer
[Music]
are you married yep yeah I'll call you
[Music]
thank you familiar very swiftly on this
[Music]
you're you're married yeah yeah how'd
you meet you won well she used to come
to my classes where I used to lecture in
this comfortable you know who spoke to
me oh you were a lecturer lecturing over
lecture
Ichi oh I don't hear very well either
and how did you meet her she was sitting
in the audience yes I was smell bound at
your lecture she was no spellbound but I
kinda she was attracted to you see and I
kept finally falling in love with her
nose you fell in love with her nose did
she have it with her particulary care
left nothing and you fell in love with
her left nostril what was the matter
with the right one
and what happened you were you walk up
to her after they liked her yeah
and what did you say - I told her I
liked you knows no this isn't your wife
[Music]
now Norma that's a very pretty name
Norman you're a very pretty girl thank
you have you always been this pretty
well I guess so huh you're a swimmer I
did you swim for a living
no I'm a low freshman at SC what kind of
course you're taking they're three
points of the started no elementary
education hmm
I won't how old are you 18 18 are you
being rushed by any of the fraternities
at school no you mean sororities
fraternities don't rush women
[Music]
things of Satan changed as I went to
school
we used to rush anything mr. Salim
Munich haven't you got a nickname
what'll I call you you know I may call
you yoga for me you court George
okay let's talk about sculptor II and
how do how did you acquire this skill
well first I was born well then I
reasonably believed then event the
famous Academy to study and then and
then I became a sculptor well how did
you decide to become a sculptor I kind
of like it appeal to my sense
I study technical think about sculptor
history of art and Anatomy well I've
studied Anatomy but I doubt if I could
ever be a sculptor however I'm a tall
I'm a pretty good wrestler
[Music]
how do you think that Norma here would
make a good statue I teach you would are
you looking at or nostril or you just
well I looking at
interesting head she has a very fine
proportion head very beautiful no any
day
now when you see a beautiful woman
what's the first thing an artist like
yourself looks for what around it'll be
square I look
[Music]
I'm surprised they don't throw me a day
lovin upon me I didn't hear the kisser I
said look at you look at the eyes for
you well I can see I'd be a total losses
of scope
a number
tamo close your eyes now I yuck you tell
me the color of Norma's eyes I don't
know I thought you just told me I always
looked at a woman's eyes yeah but that
look at the after eyes at a depth of her
solo career motion Beauty inner beauty
see what I mean
well beauty's only skin-deep and that's
good enough for me
Norma you can open your eyes now I put
my mask back on now yeah look into
Norma's eyes and tell me or what does
she look like inside happy she has
already gives her soul no
very fine expression very depth she's
all person I can see it thank you keep
looking on the inside I'll keep looking
on the other
oh yeah have you done any well-known
people and bronze or stone yes I did one
of the President Roosevelt before as I
wrote what you must be very good a lot
more respect for you now you did
Roosevelt yes and how was he did he was
he quiet when was very interesting you
see during this work he asked me says so
what you wanted to do I told him to keep
his mouth closed you see and pale
Republicans know
[Music]
the next day the newspaper
misinterpreted my story and they told
him I told him to keep his mouth shut
of course I didn't I just told it to
keep his mouth closed because of you
know when you work you have to get most
clothes you know okay I want to tell you
that we're honored to have you here I
had no idea that you were such a
talented skunk you I thought you were
one those cheap guys who stood on
Atlantic City on the beach
[Music]
Namah what is your specialty is as a
swimmer a backstroke the backstroke
couldn't could you give us an example of
the backstroke right here
well you why not I'm gonna waters
[Music]
I think that's enough it's not enough
and is there any water in the audience
kid is a kind of a what they call a dry
run okay Bad Kitty
listen and that's all you do all you do
and don't you - yeah I do it and kick
your feet at the same well thanks to you
- I know all about swimming and
sculpting and if I ever decide to have
my statue carved I'll go jump in the
lake well let's see how well you make
out in the quiz you run your 20 dollars
in the more than our other couples and
you'll get a chance at the 2,500 other
question I can't tell you how much here
are other couples one but George
Fenneman is offstage remind our
listeners the librarian and the engineer
are still ahead
with $294 here we go and see how I can
build you $20 your selected
International landmarks
there's your prize question how much
sense honey you're gonna risk uh $50
you're 15 in what country do you find
the pyramids you each if he just is
right and your uncle would start to have
$35 yes ninety five dollars remember
you're going for $2,500 nine now how
much is the 35 you're gonna bet on this
dirty hey lady
in what country do you find a Louvre
hello you BRE Louvre France and France
is right
now you have $65 $65 how much you gonna
bet this time
you bet 60 okay 60 Hyuk has a real chess
look in what country do you find the
leaning tower
he's Italian Italian right now you find
a 125 dollars
$25 is your last chance to be the other
couples how much you gonna go for I've
written 20 hundred twenty-five with that
yeah let's put the whole code is me
don't cancer y'all just know okay let's
put under 25 okay
what country do you find the Acropolis
in Greece in Greece is right
[Applause]
[Music]
and you wind up with a grand total of
250 dollars and that means the librarian
and the geologist was $294 get the
chance of the DeSoto Plymouth two
thousand five hundred dollar question
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right now we find out you've been
hanging around those books all these
years we find out if you really know
anything
here we go for $2,500 I'll give you 15
seconds to decide on a single answer
between you so think carefully and
please no help in the audience here it
is if the President of the United States
and the vice president should both
resign who is next in line to succeed to
the office of chief executive the
Secretary of State is it you stands at
three state with chief justice Nancy you
clean with a knife you can lock it over
a steak yeah talk it over
Ashley seduced me and we want one answer
this point all right what is the answer
YouTube decided upon will say the
Secretary of State no I'm sorry
according to law passed in 1947 the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
so that means the big question next week
will we wait $3,000 why do you lost the
big money but you want how much 292 or
94 dollars in the quiz congratulations
and thanks to both of you and to all of
our contestants on the show tonight
[Music]
now here he is the one the only the same
thousand dollars we had last week for
the first time in nine years we had
somebody up here who talked more than I
did and we ran out of time George you
tell him what we decided to do well last
week week missus at last week that's how
I feel last week mrs. Donald me last
week mrs. Esther Bradley and her partner
Joe Eggbert used up all our time so we
asked the other couples on our show last
week if they'd come back tonight and
they said they would do play you bet
your life and so it was mrs. Bradley is
here Joe Eggbert is here and another
partner that she picked up along the way
he's a he volunteered I think he's a
sailor so I guess they're all here now
on the show starts over just like a
regular show and we're going to play you
bet your life on the one who wins the
most money gets the chance at the $1,000
question that's right now if either of
our couples tonight say the secret word
the duck will come down and pay him an
extra $100 and the way tonight is door
all right George let's go mrs. Helen
sports mr. Isaac cashed in to purchase
first groucho so fortunately please a
meet groucho marx say the sacred word
and you'll split $100 it's a common word
something you'll find around the house
mr. Isaac cashed in and mrs. Helen
Schwarz mrs. Schwartz may I call you
Helen
yes mr. Marx you may but everybody calls
me mama well if everybody calls you mama
I don't want to be with the riffraff
I'll call you mrs. Schwartz
where are you from mr. Schwartz Paraguay
sooner or later somebody's gonna be from
Paraguay and I'm from Uruguay well I'm
longer too but
coalition's hungry lotions Russians is
the name of the city
Oh a city I thought it was something you
got in a delicatessen what do you
remember about this obscure village not
much I was about six years old when I
left there
oh that's about 35 years ago yes how did
you meet your husband Alan I assume you
have one yes I do
I met em at the dance mr. Marx because
asking know cha - no I thought that was
something you're getting a delicatessen
that's a shadow it's a holder in those
could you give us a sample in Chile
but not alone I didn't would you all
right sure I have no idea how you doing
this what I'm saving willing right what
do you do will you give us a shot over
there
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh we get acquainted fast up yeah let's
see your name is Isaac ash can no crowd
show its cashton oh you're a Japanese
cashed and is that it something like
that sometimes they say cash down oh
that's when they want to get a laugh I
guess you like that what does your claim
to fame Isaac more almost everybody are
you a [ __ ] race driver no I'm a chess
player chess are you a good player my
title is international Grandmaster
that's very impressive
now what is an international Grandmaster
is that anything like a local shape
master not quite that's the highest
title you can get in chess besides the
world's champion they're just three of
us in the United States and I think
something like 27 in the entire worlds
you must be pretty good
well they sometimes say that doesn't
frighten me in the lease guys I've
challenged you to a chess game any day
that we can bet you 500 up are you game
I'll tell ya Groucho just happens to
have a little time tonight and if you're
interested I'll play a blindfold why do
you want to blindfold yourself don't you
want to look at me well I think I can
play the game just about as well you
really think you could beat me
blindfolded
I played several people at the same time
blindfold and done pretty well Groucho
of course you realize if you're a
blindfolded I'm going to cheat well they
have referees when they do this and if I
have any choice in the referee I'll make
sure he watches you as carefully as he
does me it's pretty hard to cheat in
chess because there are very standard
international rules and if you follow
the rules this is one game where you
really can't cheat if I can't cheat
forget it
the only fun I have playing any game is
cheating
chess is a little over my head well
actually my chest is below my head could
you give me a sample play I mean a
simple one that mrs. Schwartz and I
would understand well I'll give you a
game of chess which i think is fairly
simple White's thoughts plays pawn to
King four and black plays pawn to King
four and white goes Bishop to Bishop for
and black makes the same reply and white
goes Queen to rook five blacks answer is
King Knight to Bishop three white plays
Queen takes pawn checkmate the game is
over
[Music]
mr. Schwartz when you give him $500 for
Mia well I've heard you have to be a
mathematical genius to be a good chess
players that's true or could a fellow
like me take it up well you don't have
to be a mathematical genius or a wizard
of any kind it can be illiterate
uneducated and still play a pretty good
game of chess Isaac you've described me
to a team check hands with the next
world's champion and I'm still going to
cheat
mrs. Schwartz what's your hobby
are you a chess player or do you prefer
ice hockey no samarth my hobbies movies
movies you just like some place to go to
take your shoes off
is that your popcorn happy mmm what's
right what kind of pictures do you like
musicals dramas Wesson's or comedies oh
I don't care what they are don't get
Stoney Curtis is in him well that's the
way I feel I don't care what kind of a
picture it is as long as it doesn't have
Tony Qaeda's ever why Tony Qaeda's mama
what's so fascinating about him oh
because he's just a handsomest man um on
the site he is so wonderful and and
ebony he's got talent and those big blue
eyes and he's on the screen you just
can't help did you just lose yourself
aren't you a little old to be a
bobby-soxer I should think you'd prefer
someone more mature like Clark Gable a
Bogart or Freddie Bartholomew why why
Tony caters because I'm his mother
Rick
[Music]
now one of your criticism is so
impartial does Tony come from a
theatrical family well his father was a
connector in Budapest Tony
he what did you know this when you
married mm-hmm yes well do you have any
talent outside of the type Sicari no I
just used to sing a little bit but when
de well how much thinking did you do
were you on the stage
no no max I just once called my Tony
through the window call him to come in
and I can turn a burr Wallace heard me
and he he came right over you sisters
think he said st. well you see for him
who did this a cantor mmm boy that
candor doesn't overlook a trick that's
it
while you're a nice couple and I hope
you get married someday mrs. Schwartz
I've catered you about your son but
actually I know Tony I bet dinner with
him in New York he's a good actor he's a
cute guy and he's one of the biggest box
office draws in the whole movie industry
thank you and you can be very proud of I
presume you both know how to play you
bet your life are you selected Len
London Paris and Rome as your category
these are questions on the three major
European capitals let's see you know
what you know about them remember the
more the questions what the harder it is
have you ever played chest you know I
you have any knowledge of it at all none
whatsoever
I've yet to find any subject that you
have any now
[Music]
all right now what do you want to start
with ten twenty fifty to a hundred small
sums are obviously easier than the big
ones 100 a hundred there is a famous
district of wharves and warehouses that
is a residential area for the Chinese
population of London what is this
district call it's in London believe
it's the east and groucho now it was a
famous song written about that that
that's Limehouse well you lost half your
hundred you still have fifty dollars now
what are you going to go for so try for
the ninety ninety all right Paris has
two chief airports one is Ollie orl why
what is the name of the other one very
famous in history
it's la bocha it's where Lindbergh lands
at night you don't have $25 oh well this
is just awful chess champion you want to
go to a tee
so we tried let's can you alright what
is the name of the building formerly
used as a place of imprisonment that now
houses the crown jewels of England the
Tower of London that's right the Tower
of London $105 now 70 I guess we track
the thumb is your last chance to beat
the other couples on how many hills was
Rome originally built and I want the
exact number seven tilts seven you must
be an old guy shooter 7 is right side up
with $175
[Applause]
not sure mrs. rose Westlake - mr. Miguel
Pannell are waiting to talk to you so
[ __ ] you come in please and meet groucho
marx say the sacred white and divide a
hundred dollars it's a common way
something you find around the house Rose
Westlake and Miguel canal Rose where are
you from San Francisco I was born there
right a few months before the earthquake
earthquake fire you mean well it was
both yours break started it oh don't you
ever go back to Frisco then oh I like
Cristal when I'm there like here when
I'm there like every place when I'm
there
oh yeah are you married Rose no I'm a
widow Widow have you thought about
getting married again no I have a
one-track mind I've had the nesting your
you so badly now I just want to settle
down and just feel like I belong
someplace you have a nesting egg
well Rose you're welcome to use my
avocado tree any old time
I only ask one thing of you don't cackle
before 7:00 in the morning no Miguel
Pinelli
where are you from Miguel I am from
Nicaragua Nicaragua yes sir oh that's a
nice country around their whereabouts
and Nicaragua well you know I was born
in Granada it's a very small town
Granada in Spain
no we have a new governor Nicaragua oh
that's very nice - well were you ever
involved in one of the frequent
revolutions oh I was just a child then
oh well no they have revolutions for
children down there
why are you married I'm in get you know
you're engaged yes well you mean you're
gay bachelor days are almost over
don't you miss playing the field amigo
oh I have two or three girlfriends to
carve our way yes these are spares huh
you're engaged and you have three or
four girlfriends yes you know you're oh
you're a real scoundrel they go what
does your fiance got to say about your
flitting from flower to flower oh she
doesn't know that she's Nicaragua well
you're a Central American Casanova oh
you want to call it that it's okay when
when did you last see your beloved well
no when I left Nicaragua three years ago
she still remember you I hope so
while we write each other once in a
while you know I knew Latins were great
lovers but well dog I'll still remembers
you after three years you must be
sensational you may be another Groucho
Marx visual what makes you think your
girlfriend hasn't got four or five
boyfriend's in Nicaragua she may also be
flitting from flower to flower has that
ever occurred to you why you think you
know she is very conservative on my
sister's watching her from me
[Music]
well if your sister is anything like you
I have only one question who's keeping
an eye on your sister her husband is
keeping an eye on your girlfriend all my
sister um I see to keep on a high oh my
girlfriend
what's perfectly what do you regard as
perfect I mean you have a sitting home
at night there well uh she's planning to
come all over the United States you know
mitt me and marry me
Oh me my girlfriend that means you'll
have to discard all these other yes sir
don't you regret that I do regret it
[Music]
why don't you write to your sister and
prevail upon your girlfriend to remain
in Nicaragua no because I have to get
married someday you know so better
sooner than later so well you're kind of
conditioned to this now that's it you
said where do you wake Romeo I mean may
go LM sorry well you owe me what's a cab
hardware company you work for a hardware
come yes sir will do you have any
outside interests hobbies oh yes well I
would like to be an actor you know uh
taking lessons now what have you learned
about acting well we have we have had
some basic you know very simple things
that are very important to for acting
basic yeah like a sidon how to stand
right you know who's like that you had
to learn the right and the wrong way to
sit down yet both so you can what're
your friends could you show us how you
sit down oh no I would like to try of
you George
come on bring out a chair I've never
seen a Central American sit down I'd
like to see why you would say how you
sit in the chair and I'm a been doing it
all wrong all these years I hated cloth
you know even eyes over there link back
into town okay when you go over there
but come back again huh
are you show us the correct way to sit
on yes you know you come with you sit
down then you know you can't you see has
naturally mm-hmm oh there you are
that's pretty good you know that's a
correct way now a shower station showers
the incorrect way oh the egg collector
ways can be done too many different way
you know you can come over here sit down
like that
meg well I predict in just a few short
years you'll be getting an Oscar of
course I also predicted that Pittsburgh
would win the World Series a rose how do
you feel standing this close to an
eminent act are you thrilled well no you
see I'm used to it I've been in show
business all my life you've been in show
business
oh really I should have realized you
were in show business you have that air
about you what did you do with
Shakespeare ma yeah sure
check out no I'm Fifi the chief editor
on the side so the Sheep had a good the
Rose you look perfectly normal to me in
fact you look very good in what way you
sheep headed are you fond of one gal huh
on the head I don't understand this well
you see I carried around this way I
never cut off my act you see I didn't
cut off part of this is rather
unexpected or I could probably do it
better well let me hold your hat maybe
oh that's wonderful of you I just love
being hold things for me don't go away
with it all day well I'll be back in a
few minutes she gone yet that's very
interesting when I was about 3 or 4
years old his night here just started
getting funny everybody sit over there
looks like a sheep and all that sort of
thing
so there's only two things to do if you
have something that's odd you either
conceal it or you reveal it so I decided
to cash in on a fate handed me 11 I made
lemonade out of it so I just turned
myself into
what did you do in this act now that you
got the hair like that well first of all
the man would introduce me he would say
now ladies and gentlemen we present the
inimitable Fifi now that's me now my
friends I'm called ceci the she's had a
girl I'm sure you may look at me and
know why I was discovered living among
the natives by a band of British
civilian believing me to be a child that
had been kidnapped by the natives or
perhaps the child of missionaries that
had perished in the jungle are even
perhaps natives of some race that never
has been discovered
maybe the reason so many explorers never
came home okay that's fine well I
certainly hope I never sit in back at
you at a hair-raising movie
you got a great a Crow's but what do you
do for an encore announcer I could go
into my dance oh well let's have that -
I'll get the junk bowl
[Music]
Oh
some Hawaiian music jack
get in the act
[Music]
well I'm off to the South Seas in the
morning while you're sending a couple of
odd fellows and I'd like to go on
talking
I'd like to go on talking to you too but
the Odd Fellows are meeting tonight so
let's go you betcha you won't know how
to play the game well I've played some
games I don't know about this
[Music]
this may be a little mild rose but they
won't take long
are you selected cities the foreign
country yes and your partners and one
answer between you I'll give you the
name of two cities of a foreign country
[Music]
I'll give you the names of two cities of
a foreign country and you tell me the
name of the country and remember the
more the questions what the harder it is
now what do you want to start with ten
twenty thirty up to a hundred fifty
fifty fifty s all right here in the
cities Valparaiso and Santiago what is
the country Chile Chile is right
I have $150 75 no 70 or 80 80 make 80
mmm here are the cities Calgary and
Windsor what is the country uh say again
please Calgary and Windsor Canada Canada
is correct I have two hundred thirty
dollars yeah what are you gonna go $60
$60 here the cities Auckland AUC que la
ND and Wellington you tell me the
country Australia United States Auckland
and Wellington make the United States no
it's New Zealand New Zealand you were
close Australia you lost half of your
230 and I'll have $115 all right now you
still have something to go well make it
six the game 16 oh you've had so you
failed on 60 I wouldn't try that again
although this time you'd probably know
the answer more tea no I'd say 60 70 70
okay you've had 60 70 yeah here the
city's bond and Cologne vo NN and
cologne now you tell me the country
Germany Germany is right don't go any
PUD
and you line up with $185
and that means that in just one minute
mrs. Esther Bradley and her partner's
Joe Egbert then happen to one 275
dollars last week are still high and get
the chance at the $1,000 question now
Groucho here mrs. Esther Bradley mr. Joe
Egbert and Pat hunt all set for the
$1,000 question glad to see you again we
had a lot of fun last week and I'm happy
to see you finally get the chance at the
big question and mr. egg bite have you
worked out a satisfactory way of
dividing the money with the Sailor if
you should win
yes Gratzer we've decided that we'll
split three ways well I think that's
very fair you feel all right about this
that's good well then what would you do
with your share if you should win the
night well with three children children
Groucho I have three children yes sir oh
you don't have a girl in every port all
right now let's go and good luck to all
of you now here is the big question
we're going to go for $1,000 I'll give
you 15 seconds to decide on a single end
of it answer between you so think
carefully and please no hope in the
audience on December 2nd 1955 the
American Federation of Labor and the
Congress of Industrial Organizations
merged into a single union for $1,000
who is the vice president of the afl-cio
you can talk it over the three
[Music]
all right why does the answer you three
have decided upon was a pardon was that
the president of the sir grant Union yes
yes is the president of the current
Union what'd you say before no it's a
surprisement drive at the present time
and well what is it Alissa George Meany
George Meany is right
[Applause]
where you went $1,000 and how much did
they win in the quizzed you are two
hundred and seventy-five dollars Here I
am again with two thousand dollars for
one of our couples and then even say the
secret word this moth-eaten duck will
fly down and pay him $100 the way
tonight is food scram
arrivederci George proceed Oh gotcha we
have a couple of young single people for
you tonight
and their names are miss Barbara Schmidt
mr. Mario DeRay so if you come in please
folks and meet groucho marx welcome
welcome for the new South Infiniti say
the secret word and you'll divide a
hundred dollars it's a common way
something you find around the house
Barbara Schmidt and Mario doremi a which
one is Bob
oh man that's your mama that's about the
silliest question I guess I've ever
asked on this show how do you Barbara
I'm 18 18 huh lovely age for a go back
it's a lovely age for a woman of 40 miss
Ted you're not married are you Barbara
no I'm not you're not are you engaged no
completely free agent I'm completely
unattached yeah you mean your zippers
broken
well something's holding you together
and I wish it was me where are you from
originally heaven originally I'm from
Albany New York
Albany yeah you know I live in Pasadena
oh well they tell me if you go to school
if you have a job or are you
self-sustaining or self-supporting or
what no I go to school I go to UCLA and
I'm majoring in English oh it's pretty
good you speaking at all why did you
come to California to learn English
don't they yeah speak English in Albany
yes well I prefer the climate here in
California oh you know Mario is that
your name are you Rory you're not Muriel
answer are you know the more you delay
are you related to Mario Lanza
you know with Aldo is my brother he's
related to Mario Lanza you know he's my
brother your brother's Aldo ray yeah
well congratulations you're very lucky
now then who is out oh right
he's a movies near Oh movie stuff
Johnny movie star I know is Francis X
Bushman you're a pretty big brute Mario
aren't you I'm doing yeah yeah I'm
surprised you don't play football why is
it I do play football I play for the
University of Southern California
you play with USC that's just what I say
I'm surprised you don't play football
you hate you I see I don't hate it no
time for UCLA so mine only in the last
five minutes
after now I was a fan of Rutgers
nabob I imagine life must be interesting
for a pretty girl in college I've never
been a pretty girl in college but I'm
only guessing I wasn't even a pretty
girl in high school there's anything
exciting ever happen to you Barbara the
most exciting thing that ever happened
to me was I was chosen the 1954 Rose
Queen Pasadena oh you were queen of the
rose
very high honor congratulations pretty
tough competition yes there was quite a
bit well enough let's get down to brass
tacks we've got enough of this
historical stuff for it
Mario will you marry this girl and going
steady right now
call her up until you're going to marry
Barbara if you understand women are very
understanding that way
well say yoga must be quite a - Mario if
you'll turn down the Rose Queen for her
how did you meet your innamorata
one minute about two years ago out of
dance and I liked her so a couple weeks
later I asked her out and that's it
you've been going out ever since you
were so crazy about it why did you wait
two weeks for your saving of a dime for
the phone oh he's busy doing other thing
my boy take it from an old hand on these
matters there are no other thing
why is this - Larry she's our front hit
magician no she's in Pinole California
that's about 400 miles north of LA and
she's 400 miles to meet you
she's a secretary for a district
attorney up there well that's bad you
mean your girl was 400 miles away and
you turned down a day with probably the
most beautiful girl in America who is
standing right next to you after you I
guess
no Jordan you know that's like living in
Las Vegas and going all the way to see
the rappers just to play bingo in a
choice bazaar
why you're an attractive couple and
marry off you're smart you'll marry this
girl as soon as she can support you I
forgot to ask you one question you have
a fella when did I ask you why not
I had many thought oh all right let's
play you betcha
I had a follow on to meet you it was me
they both know the rules of this swindle
this game you selected the musical
category these are all top tones to the
last 20 years and Fenneman just keep
looking right here okay now what do you
want to start with 10 20 all the way to
150 seventies mucin 70 70 ok this song
is from the score of the musical
Knickerbocker holiday now you give me
the title
honey
September zone September song is
absolutely
many dollars Oh what are you gonna take
a fling on smooth super super easy baby
McGrady $80 Sammy Cahn and Julie Stein
wrote this song about ten years ago
what's the name of it
let it snow let that's right let us know
is right now I have $250 are you going
to go for now 90 guru from 1990 this
song was a big hit a few years ago let's
see if you can identify it
wish you were here wish your way hair is
right
$340 last chance to be the other couples
what are you gonna go for we go ahead
and on $100 this song was written by
Rodgers and Hammerstein's what is the
title of it plan jack
hello young lovers that's right I get my
big
ergo that guy on the district attorney
and everything else
thanks and good luck Minnesota climate
dealer
Gaucho's and beaters the the nudie photo
Groucho Sanders and we want to drive
this car
oh what a thrill you're going to be when
you're behind the wheel DeSoto is the
smartest car smartest of the smart cars
it's the finest and now is such a sale
let's drive the new Depot all at the
photo Plymouth dealers today from every
angle from here from here or from here
this solo is smart DeSoto is the car
that makes people stop and look the car
you'll be proud to have standing in
front of your house it's smart to own
the smartest of the smart car here is
DeSoto's smart double cockpit instrument
panel with a new flight control lever
convenient but out of your way because
it's used so seldom and outside
accessing the forward look is the
dramatic splash of color we call a color
suite it's beautiful styling like this
that makes the new DeSoto the smartest
of the smart cars drive a DeSoto
before you decide go try the new be
found
gotcha we have a man with an unusual
occupation for you he's mr. Verne
lucious Cameron his partners housewife
she's mrs. Marianna Erlich so folks you
come in please and meet groucho marx
welcome to you betcha life say the
secret word and divide 100 dollars it's
a common way something you find around
the house mrs. Mariana Alec and mr. vine
lo she is Cameron a couple of pretty
fancy Monica's there Mariana
where are you from I am originally from
Czechoslovakia and I came over friends
in part two guys to the United States
you came with a friend from Portugal in
the United States
I came with my best since my husband
your best friend is your husband mm-hmm
well that may be true and Czechoslovakia
whereabouts behind the Iron Curtain did
you come from
perhaps Czechoslovakia saga you were
poor but Prague at the time could you
give us some idea of your age Mariana
I'd rather skip it when I get thrown
here I edit your a good one luminous
eyes instead did a girl with this your
age is liable to tell anything well I
expect away many other things out of you
before we go
your jewels buying lucious camera I was
named after Julesburg is that right
and you're here with them first now I
was named after yeah it's a good thing
where you from bud I was born in Sioux
City Iowa no that's where all the
lawyers come from isn't it is it I
didn't know the Hollister City I imagine
it's whoa three years an Iowa three
years in Kansas and then spent most of
my boyhood in Oklahoma what sort of life
you do Roscoe I'm a hydrologist you mean
you eat only vegetables watching a lot
of hydrologist is a man who locates or a
woman who locates underground liquids
oil and water you mean like a bootlegger
yes if they're underground well how do
you how do you go about finding water
well I have instruments that I developed
over a period of 32 years of locating
locating wells what makes this thing
work it takes on a charge from the
electrical aura around the body and this
positive charge causes it to become
attracted to the negative charge coming
up by reflection from underground water
well you lost me quite some time
have you ever found any wells for people
yes sir I've located thousands of them I
don't know how many thought well how
much you charge for finding water a cent
a gallon
well the price ranges from 25 to hundred
dollars an hour well or $100 a day flat
rate $100 a day yes sir
you must be finding water because you
said me soaking somebody that's right
thank you go on talking to you too but
the time has come to play you betcha
life in the race for the $2,000 the
first couple won $440 and the secret
word is food I'm sure you're familiar
with this game at ethics minor Owen
wants to administer the spelling quiz
this is an old-fashioned spelling bee
you get only one chance at the correct
spelling and only one answer between you
I want you to spell the word and then
pronounce it is that clear it's pellet
and pronounce it all right what do you
start with 10 20 50 all the way to 100
70 70 suits me 70 cents me too alright
spell the word lieutenant meaning an
officer military service and I you PE in
a and T right his kids from
Czechoslovakia
now I have $170 what are you going to go
for 80
hmm sure smell the white aluminum
meaning a light silver-white metal metal
ALU ni8 anomic aluminum l8l in you then
I end you end right now I have $250 you
went to night school I did I think you
know I'm day school I know how to spell
better than to pronounce no well spell
avoid fictitious meaning not real
counterfeit not genuine i i 308
marvelous except I see ti-ti or us if I
see prit oh you all right I know you
will decide one answer between it what
do you want to say yes will you want
something sure are you sure
alright a news fella fic ti ti owe us
fictitious right that's right
now have $320 I'm illiterate in the
front row is hollering you or wrong is
your last chance to be the other couples
what are you going to go for
hanji hundred all right with you all
right spell the white penitentiary
meaning a state or federal prison BCE in
a teepee or am anything cheery and I
know P yes that's what am I am alright
come on up a all away that's right yes
spell it one of yous fella pn ite m TI
AR one that is right
$440 so thanks and good luck in the
DeSoto Plymouth dealers
invited some girls who work for an
aircraft plant to our factory tonight
and just before I went on the air our
studio audience selected June French to
be on the show and her partner is mr.
Albert Hall so funky - Quinn please and
meet groucho marx welcome welcome for
the DeSoto Plymouth dealer say to see
good weight and divide a hundred dollars
it's a common word something you find
around the house mr. Albert Hall and
June French June how old are you I'm 21
21 and what's your hometown
Mineola Texas Mineola Texas is there a
town named any officer rather sad in
there well what's about 80 miles east of
Dallas even well how far is that from
Neiman Marcus
that isn't even mark Lowe are you
married yes you are yeah well you're
pretty young to be married aren't you
I've been married six years you were
married when you were 15 yes
wait catch him Riley down there no no I
caught him early oh well at least you're
honest math to admit it most women
enough mr. Haller where are you from
originally from Kansas born in Ken
don't get angry about it
trying to hypnotize
we
all right ask him anymore
if you grow up on a farm and can
did you grow up on a farm back then
Kansas sir I left those 10 years old
uh-huh your name is Albert Hall yes
that's in London is that where the
musicians play in the concerts oh yes
you did you know that were you named
after that place evidently I didn't
select the name Oh
[Music]
do you think I take a soft job up there
I come down here without my blackjack
where did you go when you left the farm
Lincoln Nebraska oh you're doing their
allowance to school when I quit school I
got a job on the Nebraska State Journal
as a printer's yep
when you ask them the next question
you were apprenticed mo well why did you
get fired maybe you want the type huh
I didn't get fired oh la Mary oh yes
oh you been married am 42 years did you
wipe out here with you yes she's in the
audience know what sort of work you've
been doing lately yeah well honest are
you the Seattle and they got a job on
the sea apple you maybe if he doesn't
win any money here
I'm leaving long before that you say you
went to see heaven you got a job on the
paper Seattle Times in the composing
room I say how long were you there
yeah
maybe I cannot frighten
why would he fit in all of dickin
stories then
don't you and what kind of work do you
do I'm a manager a friend asking you
you're a messenger well what do you do
as a messengers you deliver messages no
I deliver blueprints and supplies food
or anything else to put the engineers
water
you said food so you and gargantuan each
get $50
all right all right being a duck now who
do you deliver these things to to the
engineers
well how you addressed uh you wear this
kind of an out present oh yes skirts
blouses sweaters you know better be
careful you know I know something about
engineers they all have plans of their
own you do these engineers
maybe I can charm him
mr. hall I am reluctant to do this but
let's get back to you
what are you doing in Hollywood and who
are you fight me what are you doing here
at present mr. hall well things got
tough up in the mountains no money I
came to Hollywood to find out how they
make money well how do they make money I
walked up and down Hollywood Boulevard
and I come to the conclusion the 50% of
their on relief I think the other 40%
are going around to these banks and loan
companies is therefore never Bach I
think you've got something there now
have you decided on the type of work
that you'd like to do in Hollywood what
would you like to do how long as you're
out here now you're not doing anything
with what you're doing there looks
well it is but I don't want it to get
around that's all just I guess the jig
is up time is up the loose chatter now
that's why you bet your life in the race
for the $2,000 the first two couples are
tied with $440 you both understand the
rules of the game now you select the
geography and remember the more the
question is wait the harder it is that
if you see wait how much chief is a
hundred one hundred okay what country is
separated by one thousand miles of the
Republic of India Pakistan Pakistan is
right now you're also that's not you now
have two hundred dollars not just so we
don't have any confusion on the next
questions consult before you answer
because he might have said something
else and you wouldn't have won the money
all right what are you gonna go for now
ninety dollars now one answer what great
river is sacred to the Hindus it empties
into the Bay of Bengal Ganges gangee
just is right now have $290 hey you're
pretty lucky that a guy like that we
ready
I always been lucky all my life Groucho
I'm glad to hear that out now what are
you gonna go for yeah yeah eighty the
City of Buffalo New York is located on
which of the Great Lakes Erie Lake Erie
is right you now have three hundred
seventy dollars alright what are you
gonna go pee
there's your last chance to be the other
couples how many dollars what is the
largest city in Finland it is also the
capital now one answer talk it all the
place Helsinki that's right and you'll
wind up with
forty dollars and that means that all
Friday night in the Sheldon married or
not it doesn't make it
that means that all three of our couples
tonight in just one minute will get the
chance of the DeSoto Plymouth $2,000
question everybody tie
I have a question for you and it's a
very important one is your car safe to
drive and you see safely you steer
safely
can you stop safely well if you're not
absolutely sure take your car to your
DeSoto Plymouth dealer tomorrow you make
certain your car is a safe car you'll
make an expert check of your brakes
tires headlights taillights steering and
all other important safety features
he'll make sure your car is safe and
dependable and tell you if you need any
adjustments or repairs and if you do
you'll make them quickly
and at a reasonable cost his technicians
are specially trained and they use the
very latest equipment and factory
approved methods they'll make your car a
safe car from headlights that enable you
to see clearly at night to taillights
that enable other drivers to see you
everything that's important to your
safety will be put in tip-top condition
and it won't take long in a short time
your DeSoto Plymouth dealer will make
your car a safe car and at a reasonable
cost no matter what make of car you
drive
visit your DeSoto Plymouth dealer
tomorrow make sure your car is a safe
car
Roger here are the three couples all
tied for the DeSoto Plymouth two
thousand dollar question we've given a
little slips of paper they'll write down
one answer between them and we all get a
right we'll split the money among all of
them for $2000 what was the name of the
famous English jurist whose commentaries
are fundamental in any study of English
law
[Music]
all right were the answers mr. de ray
bhavish MIT and Mario Joe Ray's answer
is nothing
June French and alcohols answer is
nothing
Narayana Ilyich and Lane Cameron's
answer is also nothing this one has got
oil but that's wrong it's Sir William
Blackstone a very famous mate in the
history of jurisprudence I'm sorry you
all lost at me the big question next
week will be worth $2,500 well they lost
the big money but they all did pretty
well on the quiz and they George that's
all the way Monica they each win each
level one four hundred and forty dollars
well congratulations to all of you and
to all of our contestants on the show
tonight and the both of you and to
everybody else